relying on food banks for his daily
bread tomorr de ma vie is an unemployed
former soldier he feels he's hit rock
bottom left behind by the system a
feeling propelling many of the yellow
vests to protest I told myself why not
join this cause which is also mine
because if we don't act nothing will
change
struggling to pay the bills he wants to
see fundamental reforms BC lower taxes
taxes only profit the state that way
people could breathe a bit increase
people's buying power because the
minimum wage is too low they should
increase it and of course they should
stop making poor people poorer and rich
people richer dollars generation Ford
Emily the government's retreat from a
planned fuel tax hike is too little too
late like for many yellow vests although
their movement was sparked by that tax
hike it's grown into more widespread
anger at the government various groups
are making myriad demands with some
resorting to violent attacks on the very
symbols of the French Republic at its
helm president Emanuel McCaw the target
of much of the anger
just I'll stay involved until mr. McRoy
goes I won't stop protesting I'm ready
to do anything I'll even go into police
custody for my cars with online calls
for further action Frances bracing for
more protests and perhaps more violence
for more now let's bring in journalists
Jake say gonoro
in Paris Jake the yellow vests have
become a magnet for people with all
sorts of grievances new groups are
joining the movement every day do they
really share common goals that's right I
mean earlier this week we saw more than
a hundred ambulances blocked and lastly
Concord and next week farmers are
planning to join this week students also
joined high school students that is 300
high schools were affected by protests
this week and young protesters and a
commune west of France even burned a car
and clashed with police you know they
all have different complaints whether
it's taxes wages or education which
amounts to the feeling but it all
amounts to this feeling that their
living standards and their opportunities
in France are on the decline these
groups don't necessarily have a common
goal but they all do have a common
target for their protest and that would
be President Emmanuel macron and his
government well president Mike colin has
made concessions to the yellow vest
movement why have those concessions
failed to appease the voters right he's
not only made concessions I mean he's
completely axed the green taxes on fuel
and energy that year that originally
sparked these protests a month a month
ago but many of the protesters and the
political opposition say it's too little
too late they feel like they still have
a president who is completely out of
touch with the people a president of the
rich as they called him since before he
was elected mackeral himself hasn't even
publicly addressed the crisis the last
time he made a public statement was last
Sunday from the g20 summit in Buenos
Aires to condemn the violence of the
riots on Saturday but the government
announced this morning that Knothole
will speak next week now some other
politicians are trying to make political
capital of this far-right leader marine
lepen claimed in French French
television that she was quote off
yellow best the first our our right-wing
populists
profiting from the movement not at all
in fact several political parties
including marine lepen far-right
national rally the far left france
unbowed socialist center-right
Republicans they've all tried to latch
onto this yellow vest movement with zero
success protesters and people
participating in the yellow vest
movement are not really engaging with
politicians of any party and the
inability of these political parties to
gain traction with the yellow vests
especially the far right and far left
it's usually do well with marginalized
groups it signals that the yellow vests
protesters are fed up with all figures
of the political establishment Jake
thank you so much for that journalist
Jake Sagan are oh they're in Paris